so good afternoon and welcome to alumni
weekend I'd like to remind you at the
outset to turn off your cell phones and
pagers so each year the Yale Law School
Association presents the award of merit
to an esteemed alumnus and it is the
school's very highest honor the award
recognizes an individual's contributions
to the law and to the legal profession
as well as to the wider society that
each serves past honorees have included
Supreme Court justices Potter Stewart
and Byron Wright and presidents Gerald
Ford and Bill Clinton today I have the
formidable responsibility of introducing
this year's honoree a task that is made
more daunting by the fact that the
lustre of certain individuals shines so
brightly that nothing can seem to add to
it but I can say this I can say that
when Secretary Clinton left the Obama
administration earlier this year certain
pundits did speculate that she might
sometime soon
seek to add one last illusive line to
her resume
and I'm very happy to say that today
with this award we can prove them right
so there's no better place to begin than
with the Secretary's Clinton's own words
when she returned to Yale Law School to
speak at alumni weekend in 1992 that's
21 years ago Secretary Clinton then the
first lady of Arkansas told us and I'm
quoting her now part of the great
message of this law school is that being
a lawyer means many different things it
means being an advocate a legislator an
executive it means being a practitioner
and using one's skills in a variety of
areas it means being a teacher it means
taking the lessons we have been taught
and using them to help further the goals
of society as we see them so very few
lawyers today can credibly claim to have
filled each of these roles in the course
of a career but in the four decades
since she left this place Secretary
Clinton has indeed been an advocate a
practitioner a legislator in the Senate
an executive in the State Department and
a teacher to the nation and to the world
in 1969 hillary rodham was one of just
27 women in her class of 235
matriculating students the Yale Law
School was then an even more eccentric
place than it is now
professor professor Charles rice had
encamped with some students in a
makeshift tent in the courtyard and the
hog farm commune traveling and their
psychedelic bus had come to visit the
sterling law dorms and that was a period
in which even the official history of
the law school caused the dark ages but
a light shone in those dark ages at Yale
Hillary became a powerful and effective
advocate for social justice
she studied child development at the
Yale Child Study Center she consulted
with the staff of the Yale New Haven
Hospital on child abuse cases she
volunteered at the New Haven legal
assistance Association to provide legal
advice to indigent clients and to young
children
speaking to the American Bar Association
this past summer
Secretary Clinton recalled and I'm
quoting her although the work I did at
New Haven legal assistants sometimes
felt a million miles away from the
classrooms where we debated precedents
and procedures it helped me see lawyers
giving life to the concepts in my
textbooks using them to solve real
problems facing people every day
so those real problems and those real
people have been the constant
preoccupation of Secretary Clinton she
left the law school in her remarks at
Alumni Weekend in 1992 Secretary Clinton
noted that more than 1/3 of the children
in New Haven were then living in poverty
she said quoting her the problems around
us may not be so visible but they are
eating away at the quality of our lives
together and to me the key word in that
sentence is together this awareness and
compassion this keen appreciation of
interdependence have virtually defined
the career of Secretary Clinton in the
decades following her graduation she
would make compassionate and
constructive history over and over again
as a staff attorney par excellence at
Marian Wright Edelman snoo Lee created
Children's Defense Fund as a member of
the impeachment staff advising the House
Judiciary Committee during the Watergate
scan
as a co-founder of Arkansas advocates
for children and families and as the
first woman chair of the Legal Services
Corporation as the first woman to become
a partner at the storied Rose law firm
the oldest firm west of the Mississippi
as a first lady of Arkansas who became a
determined and effective advocate for
education reform as a first lady of the
United States who tirelessly worked on
the frontlines as an advocate for
families and healthcare and who formed
one half of perhaps the greatest
political partnership this country has
ever witnessed
calling to mind the days of Eleanor and
Franklin Roosevelt as a United States
Senator a legislator who tenaciously
serve the diverse constituencies of her
state both urban and rural and who after
tremendous labor in the years after 9/11
worked to secure funds to rebuild New
York to provide compensation to the
victims and to provide remedial
attention to the first responders who
worked at Ground Zero in the immediate
aftermath of the tragedy most recently
of course we've witnessed her
performance as one of the great
secretaries of state in this nation's
history after only one year in office
they were all there were already more
female ambassadors in place than at any
point in United States history and in
the State Department
at an estate department they call that
the Hillary effect in her four years at
the State Department she visited 112
countries took part in some 1,700
meetings with world leaders and logged a
staggering total of nine hundred and
fifty six thousand seven hundred and
thirty three months to speak of her
tenure at the State Department is to
speak of the course of global affairs
during the last four years from China to
Russia from Egypt to Libya from Iraq to
Afghanistan we saw progress toward
democratic reforms in Burma and she was
the first to visit there the first visit
by a secretary of state from this
country since 1990 since 1955 she
integrated everything from traditional
diplomacy to new media to development
aid to military expertise to
public-private networks to create
something called smart power and it was
smart indeed there's one particular
snapshot from her time as Secretary that
I think crisply captures the courage
that is characteristic of her career as
well as her incredible gift as a teacher
two years ago Secretary Clinton
delivered an unexpected but
extraordinary address to the United
Nations Human Rights Council in defense
of gay rights around the world and the
core of her message was this gay rights
are human rights and human rights are
gay rights
but her message was delivered with such
eloquence and such candor that it's
lesson will never be forgotten let me
read you some of the words she said to
that council she said it is a violation
of human rights when people are beaten
or killed because of their sexual
orientation or because they do not
conform to cultural norms about how men
and women should look or behave it is a
violation of human rights when
governments declare it illegal to be gay
or allow those who harm gay people to go
unpunished it is a violation of human
rights when lesbian or transgendered
women are subjected to so-called
corrective rape or forcibly subjected to
hormone treatments and it is a violation
of human rights when life-saving care is
withheld from people because they are
gay or equal access to justice is denied
to people because they are gay or public
spaces are out-of-bounds to people
because they are gay no matter what we
look like where we come from or who we
are we are all equally entitled to our
human rights and dignity
you can feel the power of those words
and she made such a strong case in front
of the potentially hostile Human Rights
Council such a persuasive case that no
representatives of the 47 member nations
walked out and indeed she received a
standing ovation and in a world of
Russian repression that is no small feat
and you should know that her speech
chimed with an equally daring and
equally memorable and effective address
that she had given in Beijing 20 years
before to the effect that women's rights
are human rights and human rights or
women's rights during during the course
of an entire career Secretary Clinton
has drawn liberally from her roots at
Yale the Law School has benefited from
her affection her close relationship to
my predecessor the great Harold Koh is
exemplary
but Harold is in truth just one of many
many members of the Yale Law community
whom Secretary Clinton has brought
within her orbit throughout her career
from Neera tanden to Karen done to Jake
Sullivan to Ronan Farrow to that guy
with the white hair and the saxophone in
recognizing Secretary Clinton with the
award of merit
therefore we pay tribute not just to her
own work as a magnificent Yale alumna
but also to the contributions that she
has enabled so many others to make she
has changed the world herself and she
has also provided a platform for other
members of our community to do the same
after eight years in the White House six
in the Senate and four more at Foggy
Bottom Secretary Clinton seems to have
decided that for her or for her there is
still plenty to change in the world
she has become a fierce and leading
advocate in the global fight to end
elephant poaching for example and just a
few months ago she launched a new early
childhood initiative called too small to
fail which will seek to improve the
health and welfare of children during
their first five years as Secretary
Clinton has aptly noted quoting her one
of the best investments we can make as a
nation is to give our kids the
ingredients they need to develop in the
first five years of life and so what
began more than 40 years ago when
Hillary Rodham went to work at the Yale
Child Study Center continues now more
eloquently than ever before in the late
1860's Otto von Bismarck described
politics famously as the art of the
possible a century later shortly before
Secretary Clinton arrived at the Yale
Law School she gave the student a dress
at her 1969 graduation from Wellesley
College and she said quote the challenge
now is to practice politics as the art
of making what appears to be impossible
possible in her decades of public
service Secretary Clinton has accepted
that challenge and miraculously she has
met it she has proved Bismarck wrong
she has become throughout the many
chapters of her career one of the truly
great stewards of our national trust as
a practitioner an advocate a legislator
an executive a leader and as a teacher
she has proved Bismarck wrong time and
again she has made the impossible
possible and she has become a great
champion of our national aspirations and
ideals for the extent of her
achievements and the power of her
example and for the dazzling future we
know is yet to come please join me in
welcoming the recipient of the 2013 Yale
Law School Association Award of Merit
Hillary Rodham Clinton
thank you
thank you so much thank you thank you
Dean Post for those much too generous
words but that walked down memory lane
that you just provided me I also want to
thank President Sall of a thank you very
much as well mr. president and everyone
at the law school in the university for
this extraordinary honor it has gone to
many lawyers and leaders who I respect
and admire including the one I am
married to so I am deeply humbled to
stand in their company I also want to
acknowledge senator dick Blumenthal who
is here I thank you so much dick and
your family and keep up the good fight
on behalf of the people of Connecticut
I'm also told that former Senator John
Danforth is here and I wanted to
acknowledge him and thank him for his
his years of leadership and stewardship
I look out at this audience and I see so
many friends and colleagues I could keep
you here for many hours telling you
stories only if you swear not to take
them out of the room but I want to
acknowledge Harold Koh yes he was your
former Dean
he was also my state department legal
adviser and Herald and I had a lot of
adventures over the past four years from
negotiating the freedom of a blind
Chinese dissident to co-starring in a
photo that became a viral internet
sensation
now the meme was called text from
Hillary but Harold is right there with
me
depending upon the angle his eyes are
either open or shut but I understand
that he's thinking of capitalizing on
his newfound celebrity by teaching a
class called text from Harold statutes
in 140 characters or less if anyone
could do it Harold could now just out of
the frame of that photo on the c-130 is
Jake Sullivan class of o3 who is also
here celebrating his tenth reunion after
four years and nearly a million miles by
my side at the State Department
Jake is now national security advisor to
Vice President Biden
so if Vice President Biden starts
wearing pantsuits and scrunchies I think
we know who to blame but I greatly
appreciate all of you who have been part
of the journey that bill and I have been
on most particularly the class of 1973
our friends and colleagues and also some
from 72 which is where I started
it is really hard to believe as I look
at some of the students in the audience
that it's been 40 years I remember the
first time I arrived on campus in 1969 I
was driving a beat-up old car I had a
mattress tied to the roof I was wearing
my bell-bottoms and I'm so grateful
there was no internet or phone cameras
in those days I was as Dean Post said
one of 27 women out of 235 law students
there was a camp set up in the square at
the law school the common it was not
quite clear what it was for but it
seemed to fit right in with the mood of
the time it was a tumultuous time in
America in New Haven and at Yale and the
students were drawn in we had a lot of
late night heated arguments over the
future of the country
we even challenged each other whether
going to law school at such a time was a
morally defensible choice in other words
were we selling out what would we do
with the rest of our lives thanks to the
steady leadership of President Kingman
Brewster who suspended classes during
the worst of the unrest and opened the
dorms to anyone who needed a meal there
was on the campus at least some feeling
that we could get through this together
those were the days of Reverend William
Sloane coffin one of the most articulate
voices of the anti-war movement the law
school Dean Dean Lewis Pollock urged us
to organize student patrols after the
international law library was actually
set on fire and I remember being part of
the bucket brigade trying to save those
priceless materials so the
times themselves certainly left
indelible memories but it was my
professors and my classmates who most
influenced me and shaped the kind of
lawyer I became and the choices that I
made
I took fascinating challenging classes I
made a lot of friends and one day
cutting through what was then the
student lounge with some of those
friends my second year I heard a voice
say and not only that we grow the
biggest watermelons in the world I grew
up outside of Chicago I said who is that
the answer was that's Bill Clinton he's
from Arkansas and that's all he ever
talks about so I was curious those were
the days when he looked like a Viking
from Arkansas and we kept kind of
looking each other you know I'd walk by
on the street or in the hallway and I'd
look at him and he'd look back but we'd
never been properly introduced
so one day in the law library I was
looking at him and he was looking at me
we were both supposed to be studying of
course so I got up and I walked over and
I said if you're gonna keep looking at
me and I'm going to keep looking back we
at least ought to be introduced I'm
Hillary Rodham who are you now you know
bill tells a much better story he says
well I totally forgot my name
but he quickly recovered and we had a
conversation that started that day and
has continued to this one I want just
briefly to share a few of the lessons
that I learned outside of the classroom
that continued to influence how I see
the world and the challenges facing our
country now it was here as dean post
reference that I developed a lifelong
passion about children's welfare and I
learned that if you want to know about
the moral economic and social health of
a community look at the children it all
began with a little flyer on the law
school bulletin board outside the
Registrar's Office now I haven't been
over there on this trip so I don't know
if there are still those Flyers but we
used to study them like we were studying
the Talmud because you never knew what
you'd find on that bulletin board you
might find a note saying would anyone
like to take a course next year about
the legal ecological challenges of the
Central African forest I mean that was
Yale and there was always somebody
willing to teach it and to take it well
that day I saw a little note about a
woman named Marian Wright Edelman who
was going to lecture on campus I had
just read about her in Time magazine she
was a 1963 graduate of the law school
and the first african-american woman
admitted to the Mississippi bar she was
a lawyer for the n-double-a-cp in
Jackson she was a friend of dr. King and
Bobby Kennedy
she was an altogether remarkable person
so I went over to hear her speak and I
was captivated
she talked about the political
importance of taking care of kids and
why she as a Yale Law School graduate
was focused on starting a head start
program in Mississippi how she wanted to
use her Yale education on behalf of poor
children something just clicked with me
and I went up to her afterwards and I
said I really want to come to work for
you this summer
she said that's great but I have no
money to pay you and I was paying my way
through law school and I had to make
some money so I went back to the
Registrar's Office and started looking
around for something that could pay my
way and I discovered the law student
civil rights Research Council gave out
grants so I applied for one and I got it
and because of that I was able to spend
the summer of 1970 researching the
plight of children of migrant
farmworkers who often lived without the
basics of Housing and sanitation it was
an eye-opening experience and I returned
to Yale that fall with a new sense of
focus and mission I had two professors
Jay Katz and Joe Goldstein who
encouraged my interest in how the law
could better protect children and
families and suggested that I spend time
at the Yale Child Study Center so I
began to do so attending case
discussions observing clinical sessions
getting to know the incredible dr. Sally
province a pioneer and early childhood
development who helped stressed-out
parents understand that talking and
reading lovingly to your babies even
when they were far too young to talk to
you would have lasting benefits and this
was before all the brain science this
was just understanding the absolute
imperative of human connections with our
youngest people that insight really was
driven home to me when I started
consulting with the medical staff
Yale New Haven Hospital about child
abuse child abuse was just being
recognized as a problem in the early
1970s I accompanied doctors on their
rounds I was just a law student but I
was interested so they treated me like I
knew something and I would be asked well
so what do we do what's the law on this
and is there any law that we should be
consulting I saw children who had been
beaten and burned who'd been left alone
for days and squalid apartments who
didn't get the medical care they needed
in a timely way and I remember one
father who brought in his badly injured
three-year-old claiming that he had to
beat the boy to get the devil out of him
now I'm sure there was child abuse and
domestic violence when I was growing up
but I didn't see it and it wasn't
covered in the press so it was a hidden
silent problem like so many others and I
began to see how the health and
well-being of children was a real window
into the health and well-being of our
country kids were the Canaries in the
proverbial coal mine and if you want to
understand even today how economic
dislocation of the past dozen years has
affected American life look at our
children more than 16 million American
kids live in poverty today the highest
percentage since the early 1990s nearly
half of all recipients of food stamps
are children 22 million of them and yes
the overall poverty rate here in New
Haven is just over 25% but for children
it's nearly 38% and in Hartford
Connecticut it's more than 50% just
think about that for a moment
Connecticut is one of our wealthiest
states and more than half the children
in its capital live in poverty
if you want to understand our health
challenges many of which are correlated
to economic troubles look again at our
children the prevalence of chronic
conditions like obesity asthma
behavioral and learning problems among
American children has more than doubled
in the past two decades and despite all
of the advances that we have made babies
in America today are more likely to be
born underweight and undernourished than
they were in 1990 if you even want to
understand the human costs of political
brinkmanship and gridlock in Washington
look at the children because of the
government shutdown nearly 9 million
women and children will soon be unable
to buy healthy food and baby formula
through the special supplemental
nutrition program for women infants and
children already nearly 19,000
low-income children younger than 5 can
no longer attend Head Start programs and
that's on top of the 57,000 children who
have been turned away because of the
sequester so if you really want to
understand what this means when we talk
about growing inequality and shrinking
social and economic mobility that is
undermining America's ideal of equal
opportunity for all look at the children
I was very struck by the important new
research coming from Robert Putnam
he finished his PhD in political science
here at Yale when I arrived for law
school he later earned acclaim for his
work on the changing nature of America's
civic engagement and community networks
in his seminal study called Bowling
Alone a dr. Putnam is studying today how
economic pressures on parents translate
into less time and support for kids who
start off behind
and struggle to catch up in the 1960s
and 70s parents with different income
and educational achievement levels were
all spending similar amounts of time
reading to their children but over time
a gap emerged dr. Putnam and his team
have looked at what they call diaper
time when parents address the immediate
needs of their young children and
they've also looked at what they call
good night moon
time when they talk read and interact
with their kids I love this because that
book was very big at our house now the
research shows that everyone does diaper
time you have two or the very least that
will happen is the baby will keep crying
but parents with lower income less
education who struggle to work two jobs
with few benefits or flexibility many of
them single moms parents without strong
support networks they are spending
significantly less good night moon time
each day than more affluent families and
less than parents in comparable
positions did thirty and forty years ago
this lost time adds up children build
their vocabularies by listening to and
interacting with their parents and
caregivers and by age three children
from low-income families with less good
night moon time have learned on average
half as many words as children from
middle and upper income families so that
by the time they enter school they have
substantially smaller vocabularies than
many of their classmates experts call
this the word gap in addition the new
brain research is showing how growing up
with the stresses of poverty can damage
the development of the prefrontal cortex
which is associated with the ability
pay attention exhibit self-control
organize and plan among those born in
2001 only 48% of poor children started
school ready to learn compared to 75% of
children from middle-income families and
this disadvantage leads to further
disparities in achievement and success
over time and even to lower earnings and
lower family stability twenty and thirty
years later now we all agree that every
child deserves the best possible chance
at success in America but we are seeing
a cycle of economic pressure and
inequality that will make it harder and
harder as the years go by for millions
of American children to succeed in
school and in life and these children
are telling us in their own ways what we
need to do now when I was working with
the doctors at the hospital I also
volunteered at the New Haven legal
services and I saw a lot of real world
examples that made a big impression on
me and helped me decide that I wanted to
wage legal battles on behalf of poor and
broken families but person by person
family by family it just wasn't enough I
grew up in a family that prized
self-reliance we were surrounded by
friends neighbors church leaders
community members all of whom really
believed how important it was to support
the next generation but the Legal
Services office here in New Haven
I met too many people children and adult
alike who didn't have that web of
support and it struck me that somehow we
have to recreate that web we have to be
there
with that concern not just rhetorically
but in practice confidence in our most
important institutions has fallen to
historic lows
polls show Americans losing faith in the
press in banks and sports heroes and
religion and of course in Washington
yeah think about our democracy Trust is
the thread that weaves together our
social fabric the lessons that I learned
here and the tools I acquired by
attending law school has made me even
more determined that we have to try to
reverse these trends for our sake not
just the sake of those who are being
left behind and left out so at the
Clinton Foundation where I'm working
with Bill and Chelsea we're taking on
this word gap we're partnering with the
next generation foundation and we've
launched a campaign called too small to
fail we're gonna try to use social media
we're gonna try to work with businesses
we understand that we're not gonna get
on a new program of some kind from
Congress right now but there's a lot we
can do even without that and to build
support and understanding of the
importance so we will be conducting
public action and social media campaigns
and we will be working to try to raise
the visibility of this issue now when I
talk about too small to fail or the word
gap a lot of very well-meaning concerned
people think it's somebody else's job I
think it has to be somebody else's job
but I think it's all of our job I think
it is what we have to do now to try to
reverse this tide
of inequality that is eating away at the
social fabric of our country and yet at
the same time I am confident we can it's
a serious problem with very large
consequences but it's one we know what
to do to address I remember a long
conversation that I had back at Yale in
the midst of all the turmoil the world
did seem to be coming apart and kids we
had grown up with were dying in Vietnam
with the eight black panthers on trial
in the courthouse off the green
thousands of angry protesters filled the
streets of the city for students at Kent
State in May of 1970 were shot dead by
National Guard troops
so it was a distressing difficult time
but in 1971 I was fortunate enough to
share a dorm room with a young woman
from Burma who I think is here named
Quan Quan Tong she later married another
classmate bill Wong she was smart she
was beautiful she was a great dancer I
had never been anywhere like Asia in my
life it seemed very far away and I asked
her why would you come here why would
you want to be at Yale Law School at
this time well she came for the same
reason people still come by the millions
and even more wanting to come because
she still saw the opportunity and the
freedom the place to get the best
education in the world or to start a
business or express an opinion or pursue
a dream and so when I knew I was going
to Burma as part of our effort to open
up the country and begin a relationship
I called quan cong and i said what do
you think that it's time it's time to go
yes it had been ruled by a repressive
military regime but they were reaching
out and we needed to reciprocate one of
my favorite moments was when i was
speaking with one of the burmese
generals who had taken off his uniform
and was now the speaker of one of the
houses of parliament and he told me we
have been studying your country trying
to understand how to run a parliament
and i was very proud to hear that i
thought maybe you know the law school
could run some seminars or something I
said so you've been having workshops and
meeting with people he said oh no we've
been watching the West Wing so we get
messages out in all kinds of ways but
they looked to us as they try to make
some tough decisions and we need to know
the responsibility that comes with that
we have so many blessings right now in
our country even in these difficult
times it's no surprise that students
from 118 countries more than I visited
are represented here that's because
people the world over know that Yale and
America is a center for excellence and
creativity I've always felt that way I
remember a conversation with a good
friend who asked me if you could live in
any country in any century where would
it be and people were talking about you
know ancient Rome Victorian England but
honestly I said then and I feel it just
as strongly today I would live right now
in America the chances we have to keep
moving in the right direction together
toward that more perfect union are even
greater today than they were 40 years
ago yes we have big challenges ahead of
us but we have the ability if we match
it with the will
to meet every challenge we face it will
take all of us working together it will
take not only leaders but citizens who
have to dare greatly and lead boldly but
that's when we're at our best it's in
our DNA it's what truly are the habits
of the heart that de Tocqueville
identified so many years ago Yale is a
place that's been around since the
beginning has seen the ups and the downs
some of which I witnessed but keeps
going from strength to strength that's
exactly like the country that has
nurtured it all of these years so I
thank you Yale for this honor I thank
you for introducing me to the law to
many friends to my husband and I thank
you for opening my eyes to the world
around me in a way that I had never
experienced and giving me the
opportunity to learn about the
contributions I could make that is the
greatest gift of any education and it is
one that I hope is being seized by the
students of today and tomorrow thank you
all very much